est-ce que vous êtes sensible à la
politique nataliste de Monsieur Michel
Debray qui demande justement d'avoir
trois enfants même qu si vous voulez
voyez je trouve que il a peut-être des
raisons mais il fait pas grandchose pour
aider les gens qui veulent avoir quatre
enfants les élev c'est un problème ça
prend du temps de l'argent et tout ça
c'est pas monsieur debr qui les élèvera
j'en ai trois ça suffit amplement vous
avez vous-même des enfants combien de TR
c'est beaucoup trop c'est beaucoup
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
Monsieur Michel debr qui demande
justement d'avoir tro enfants par couple
au moin force une force une famille qui
n'a que un enfant ou deux enfants c'est
quand même triste voyez disons que quand
on peut les élever les enfants comme en
France il y a de quoi vivre la situation
de notre pays m'encourage pas tellement
à à les conseiller en avoir beaucoup TR
c'est un non sens et ne pas en avoir du
tout c'est c'est peut-être un non sens
aussi par ménage ça ferait quand même
pas mal de de gens il y aurait quand
même peut-être un manque d'emploi ou pas
mal de choses quoi on sera toujours
assez nombreux